history says historical drama Vikings is
curly in the final hiatus of its run
sometime later this year viewers will
get to see the epic conclusion of the
Scandinavian saga and learn the fates of
Ragnar surviving sons well except for
one of them who was and ceremoniously
left out of the series altogether if
you've been following Vikings you
probably think that original protagonist
Ragnar lothbrok sired enough
bloodthirsty sons to satisfy any
medieval Norwegian King interestingly
his offspring are more than mere
invention as we actually have historical
sources for the existence of all the
sons of Ragnar portrayed on the show the
historical Ragnar did indeed have two
wives and those two wives actually bore
him more sons than we get to see
squabbling on Vikings aside from passing
references in the late 9th century
anglo-saxon Chronicle our best
contemporaneous information about the
life of Ragnar lothbrok and two sons
comes from the sagas an incomplete
collection of Norse Danish Swedish and
Icelandic mythology from the Viking Age
that only survives in partial form well
some scholars have argued that the
accounts of Ragnar and his progeny
should be taken as folklore or mere myth
some of the events chronicled in these
stories line up well with the better
sauce English histories of the so called
great heathen invasion according to this
historical record Vikings is missing one
of Ragnar sons
during the time period alluded to in the
sagas and explicitly covered by the show
a massive Scandinavian army landed on
the northern and eastern coast of
England and very nearly wiped out the
dominant anglo-saxon civilization
through successive waves of invasion the
events of these Viking invasions were
dramatized on the fourth and fifth
seasons of Vikings in which the sons of
Ragnar sail to England to avenge the
death of their father but the hands are
the northumbrian King interestingly
Ragnar death in the northumbrian snake
pits also comes directly from the sagas
see thank ya here for the historical
record includes references to all the
sons of Ragnar the fans of the series
have come to know love and loathe uber
and Ivar in particular play an outright
soul in the historical he's an invasion
of England historical accounts also make
reference however to another lothbrok of
arguably greater imports the many of the
characters who are included on the show
Halton ragnarson was supposedly a Viking
warlord alongside his brothers uber and
IVA he led men in the crate an army of
the eight 60s a nearly wiped Wessex off
the map so where is he on Vikings Halton
is named in the sagas but also in
Icelandic epic poetry he has explicitly
cited as one of the many sons of Ragnar
lothbrok according to these literary
accounts he is believed to be the fifth
son of Queen L slug Ragnar second wife
since both Ragnar and I'll slug have
already been dispatched on Vikings we
know no additional son is forthcoming
from their union was this just an
oversight what gives Houghton's
inclusion wasn't for lack of source
material he lived an impactful life at
least on par with that of his siblings
the historical record places often in
Wessex proper at the time of the great
heathen invasion he ultimately settled
in Northumbria a region of England under
extensive Danish control at the time he
died there sometime around 877 even
though Vikings paid around with the
timing of these events Hall stones
historical accomplishments certainly
intersected substantially enough with
the story crater Michael Hirst
was trying to tell to merit at least
some consideration according to the
Daily Express Perce actually had a
rational historical reason for excluding
Haughton from a series per Hearst
research prior to drafting the pilot he
discovered that the Norse Sagas he was
mining for source material never
mentioned Halton and hvitserk one of
Ragnar's other sons in the same accounts
hvitserk is the name favored in those
stories Marez often is cited in the
anglo-saxon accounts as a result some
scholars have reached a conclusion that
Halton and hvitserk may actually be the
same person since the whole of prague
saga is of dubious historical authentic
it's entirely possible that this would
be the case instead of bloating the cast
with an additional loft Brock Sun first
opted to agree with the scholars arguing
the
often and hvitserk were one in the same
so in some sense Halton is included in
the popular series just under a
different name so I understand the first
half of Viking season 6 is currently
streaming on Amazon Prime and history
catch up before the final rating party
launches by the end of 2020 check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos by your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and to the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]